Welcome to Office Hours. The first thing I'm going to talk about is homework 3.
There was a lot of confusion on how to do the permalink part, which is mostly my fault.
I will explain what I intended for you to do using this handy-dandy whiteboard.
Okay, the first thing you need to do when you store an object,
you're going to make a post, and it's going to look something like this.
You're going to be making this post object, and it has a title and some contents.
I think that was it, but that's not the important part. Most of you figured this out.
When you put the post in the database in Google App Engine,
you use the put() command to do so.
That actually stores the post in the database.
Once you've stored it in the database, that's when Google App Engine assigns that post an ID.
You can also include an ID in this constructor here when you build it,
but generally it's best just to let the database do it itself, because otherwise you have
to keep track of which IDs you've used, which ones you haven't used--that sort of thing.
We'll let Google set the ID.
We'll put it in the database, and then what we need to do is redirect the user
to the permalink page for that post, and by permalink, I just mean link to that post.
We need to get this post ID. The way we do that is just say p.key().
Key() is Google App Engine's full representation of this object,
and this is whole long string.
You can turn this into an integer by calling ID on it.
This is the integer representation of that post,
and we'll convert it into a str--pardon my indentation here.
We'll assign this to a variable.
What we'll do then is we'll redirect the user to a URL with this variable in it.
It'll look something like this.
Then we're going to use our string substitutions to include a little string here.
This should redirect the user to /blog/ the ID of this post.
That's the first part of the problem.
The key thing here that you need to know is how to get the idea of a post you just submitted.
Now, let me erase this and then the second part of this problem is
how do you actually look up that blog post.
Now, you've got your URL mappers.
All the URL mappers that we've done in the class are basically static URLs.
They have the format of something like--remember these are tuples at the bottom of that file.
It might look like '/blog/' and this maps to a handler that just draws a blog.
In my code, I think it's just called main page, which is the Google default for that first one.
Now, we want to do is we want to make a special one for linking to permalinks.
These strings here that represent the URL are not just strings.
They're actually regular expressions.
We had some regular expressions in Unit 2 when we were validating usernames
and passwords and that sort of thing.
Well, what we want to have here is a regular expression
to capture a URL with an integer after it.
That looks something like this.
This is all just normal string.
In a regular expression you can just have anything that's just kind of regular text
just matches that text exactly.
Now, after here we use parentheses to basically say whatever goes in here
will be passed as a parameter to our handler function.
We can do something like this: [0-9]+.
What this means is the square brackets say match any character between these square brackets.
You can use ranges like this.
This basically says find any number 0 through 9, and the plus means find one or more of them.
This will basically match any URL that starts with /blog/ and then any number,
and we'll map that to some handler for our permalink page,
which I think in my code I may have called "post handler,"
but you can call that whatever you want.
That's step 2. It's basically do this URL handler. May I have the eraser, please?
Then we'll talk about step 3, which is fairly straightforward. There we go.
You have your handler, so we'll have something that looks like this,
and this inherits from that webapp2 handler or the global handler, whichever you're using.
Then here you have a function that looks something like this: definite get--
this handles get requests.
Normally, this just takes one parameter called "self."
In this case, we had parentheses in the URL mapper, which means it's going
to match whatever is in those parentheses and pass it as a parameter to here.
In this case it's going to be our post ID.
One quick thing to note. I never call variables ID in Python because ID is actually a function.
It's a reserved function, and it's really easy to create really subtle bugs
if you start using the word ID.
All my variables that refer to IDs always are something_id.
Now what we want to is get our post out of the database.
In App Engine this just looks something like this: p = Post--
this is our class that we defined that's the actual data model.
You can say getbyid(post_id).
That'll do a database query to look up the post with ID out of the database.
Then all you need to do is if p, and then you can render it however you planned on doing that.
If p doesn't exist you can just return a 404.
That's how you do the permalink portion of the homework.
I hope you guys manage to get all this working. I'm sorry.
I probably should have covered getbyid in the lecture,
but that's the fun of teaching for the first time.
Good luck everybody and thanks for sticking with us so far.